we started looking at area and we looked
at a few different shapes right we
looked at four of them remember what
they were what do we start with
we started with squares right and then
we move on to rectangles then triangles
and then we moved on to parallelogram
unfortunately someone has some extra
memories I don't know sons mess with you
we did not look at will next week then
so I want to call your memory back to
you in particular the parallelogram okay
have a look at it now can you remember
how did we work out the area for the
parallelogram we had to play a bit of a
trick with it right what did we do you
remember right okay so let's come back
over here let's see if we can remember
let's see if we can recite area of a
square if the sides are all like yes
what was our formula s square very good
if you've got length and breadth then
your formula for the rectangle is length
times Bradley if you've got the base and
the perpendicular height of a triangle
then what's its area 1/2 base times
height or base height ok
and then we came to the parallelogram
and we said 'if I can't divide it up
into rectangles or squares right I had
to do something else with it who can
remember Nathan you had to end up like
like it was a good line at the end where
it's like okay ha no let's take that
idea and see if we have language that
can better describe this right the
reason why like Matz and every other
subject out there invents new words is
because of the exact sentence that just
came out of Nathan's mouth right now
which hardly you knew what he's talking
about and the other half of you do not
okay so let's try and take those ideas
you said to put a line somewhere every
here
what kind of shape am I going to make
I'm going to make a triangle
not just any triangle though what kind
of triangle do I want over right angles
very good so I want Knight degrees there
right which means that blue dotted line
I just drew it has a particular name
starts with an A something that we use
to describe when you know planes are in
the air and we say how high are they
right it's altitude right so you've got
this altitude here creates a new
triangle right and then what do we do
with that triangle we we move the robot
dinner we okay we moved it round to this
side okay and this was the shape that we
ended up with okay does that make sense
so we lost this triangle over here
now we're getting this one and then haha
magic it's rectangle and the point is
that what you did in the first place was
you considered one shape as a bunch of
other shapes in this case too and then
you could shift them around okay so what
we did was we considered the area or
what we call a composite shape it's a
shape that's divided up into other
shapes okay and that's what you're
looking at with the [ __ ] in front of you
now these are not hard um all the shapes
that I've given you are some combination
of these four shapes that we squares
rectangles triangles or parallelograms
okay
or they'll be kind of like rectangles
take away squares or triangles take away
rectangles or some other kind of
combination okay
so I'm just going to go through one
example show you how not to do it and
show you how to do it and then the rest
of them you can have it go out
that's an all right cool in your books
I'd like you to start by having a look
at one a with me which you already
should have done when I was walking
around let me start by showing you how
not to do it and I'll get my red pen out
so you can see what I'm gonna do
okay sorry what ain't here's what I'm
gonna write down I've got ten twelve
eighteen that looks to me like 10 plus
30 which is 40 and it's an area meters
set up there's my insult okay Part B so
this is how not to do it right now
there's a lot of things wrong with this
apart from the fact that the answer is
wrong but I want to unpack why it's
wrong and what we can do to improve it
okay suggestions okay alright so the
first thing that's wrong is I've added
these things up together if it's an area
what am I gonna have to do instead I'm
gonna have some multiplication just like
here in here and here okay so that makes
sense so if for starters this is the
wrong process okay but further than that
even if we had the numbers right and the
multiplication right if this is wrong
you have no way of really determining
why it's wrong because there isn't
enough information okay now I know I've
supplied diagrams to you but I would
like it right now to draw your own
diagram make it a bit bigger than this
one so that we can put up an information
on it okay and I'm gonna do the same so
draw it with me okay now here's the
first step he's the first way to make
sure that we gonna get this right okay
they very conveniently divided up this
shape for you they weren't always to do
that you'll sometimes have to work out
how to divide it yourself okay but being
that they've done it for us let's now
label these areas I mean call this one
area one and area two
if you wanted to you could call it you
know area of this rectangle over here an
area of this triangle okay but sometimes
it's not quite so obvious which ones
which or maybe you've got a whole bunch
of rectangles and you don't wanna say
area of this rectangle an area of that
rectangle I've got numbers it's
completely unambiguous so it's having
your area one
area okay so it's a rectangle so much
for me am I going to use next time Brett
right thanks Testament so I've got a
lengthier and a Brett so 10 by 12 very
good so it's 120 and it's an area so
meat is squid okay so I've worked at my
first one now I work out my second one
ok let's try someone else Nathan
it's a triangle so which one we're gonna
use Jake okay huh times base times
height now hold on a second
I don't actually have on there what the
base is right because in another color
here is the base but I don't have a
number just on that how you gonna work
it out Amy fantastic so you can see
you're going to use the information on
there to work out what you need 18-12 of
course is six okay so there's our base
right square yeah yes yes that's how you
would work that up if you wanted to
they keep in mind being that we only
need the base and the height which we
already have in this particular case you
won't need the hypotenuse I guess if you
wanted the perimeter you would or if it
was a different kind of shape that might
be useful to you so that's how you would
do it okay
1/2 times base which you just decided
times and it shares the same height as
the rectangle right so that sounds like
birdie to me okay done so now we can
write the total area which is of course
one plus two which is a hundred n okay
now in this particular example okay
because it starts off pretty gently you
probably could have gotten away with on
asleep just writing down the numbers and
then ending up with your number okay
your final area but as you can see if
you cross your eyes down the sheep that
kind of approach without describing
what's happening and labeling all that
kind of thing is going to become less
and less reliable okay you're gonna
forget areas or get the dimensions wrong
all those kinds of things if you have
your whole working written there then
you can make sure it's right if you have
an area you can trace back to where it
happened rather than just like my final
numbers wrong don't know why it's wrong
guess I'll just move on okay